il y a eu ce conseil national vous voyez
des images en fin de semaine ou madame
anglade et le parti libéral ont décidé
de dévoiler la plateforme électorale
tout de suite la plupart du temps crois
que ça avait déjà été fait mais ce
charest l'avait fait d'autres l'ont fait
monsieur martin je pense et réflexions
aussi au fédéral mais bref on attend
pendant la campagne habituelle en mai la
madame anglade a décidé de mettre
clairement dans le jeu politique
ou aux gens qui au citoyen qui vont
voter des propositions assez concrète
elle est avec nous madame anglade bon
soir dans ça se voit et ce qui est
ressorti des propositions que j'avais
fait entre autres moyens hydro québec
soit vous l'aviez déjà dit remarquer la
tvq sur les biens de première nécessité
que vous allez enlever hydro québec vous
l'avez rajouter vous allez proposer un
gel jusqu'à temps qu'on revienne à une
forme de régie de l'énergie mais ce qui
a retenu l'attention cvo baisses
d'impôts pourquoi proposer des baisses
d'impôts maintenant parce que vous voyez
comme moi monsieur roy quel point
l'inflation au joue un rôle important
dans le quotidien des québécois on a de
la misère à joindre les deux bouts
misère à payer le loyer l'épicerie et on
sait que ça va être dur et on sait que
c'est pas sur une courte période que ça
va se passer donc il faut des
propositions qui vont faire en sorte que
ça va être structurant que ça va
permettre d'aider les québécois dans le
quotidien mais sur une longue période
c'est pour ça que la réduction d'impôt
est importante parce qu'elle permet
justement de remettre à chaque personne
dans ses poches un millier de dollars
jusqu'à un millier de dollars et pour
passer à travers les prochains mois puis
les prochaines années donc c'est quelque
chose qui s'inscrit dans le long terme
et ça s'adresse à tout le monde parce
que vous dites je vais augmenter
en contrepartie l'impôt sur le revenu
pour les gens très riches la 300 milles
et plus mais les deux premiers paliers
d'impôt tout le monde auront auront
droit tout le monde aura droit à 1 25%
diminution pour les deux premiers
paliers absolument parce que on veut
toucher une grande majorité de personnes
parce que jouer les deux bouts pour la
classe moyenne aujourd'hui ça veut dire
beaucoup de la grande majorité des
québécois puis encore une fois on sait
que c'était une crise qui va qui va
durer pendant ce temps le gouvernement
engrange des montants supplémentaires il
ramasse de l'argent à l'inflation
augmente donc le rire les revenus de
l'état sont plus importants donc
redistribuer ça le plus rapidement
possible ça nous paraît être la bonne
chose à faire tout en disant aussi qui
aura d'autres mesures le transport le
transport en commun par exemple il sera
qui sera gratuit pour les étudiants qui
sera gratuit pour les aides pour les
aînés plusieurs autres mesures qui vont
venir aider encore davantage la carte ou
le transport en commun vous êtes partout
où je vais compenser les les sociétés de
transport absolument absolument et
encore une fois lorsqu'on parle par
exemple pour les aînés accompagner
davantage nos aînés une allocation est
née à partir de l'âge de 70 ans donc
plusieurs mesures qui vont faire en
sorte que à long terme ça va aider la
classe moyenne et les 1000 à court terme
également tout de suite on va pouvoir
les mettre en application de la fin des
de la fin de la campagne électorale donc
c'est ça l'objectif est le message puis
vous savez que dans les dernières années
des deux dernières années on n'a pas pu
être sur le terrain que non comme on
aurait aimé l'être alors c'est une
opportunité de le faire en amont de
l'élection parce que il nous reste peu
de temps et en cinq semaines de campagne
électorale c'est difficile de placer
toutes les mesures qu'on veut mettre de
l'avant mais vous ou craignez pas qu'en
le disant maintenant derrière monsieur
legault aujourd'hui a dit moi y'a rien
qui dit que je vais pas promettre des
baisses d'impôts aussi etc j'ai pas peur
que vous allez y voir une surenchère et
que vous ne serez plus la seule à
proposer des baisses d'impôts dans un
mois au delà des propositions qu'on va
faire de toute façon je pense qu'aussi
que la question qui va se poser ses
qualités de leadership parce qu'on veut
à voir quel genre de personne on va
avoir la tête du québec est-ce qu'on
veut avoir quelqu'un qui est allé côte
où quelqu'un qui est arrogant comme l'a
été françois legault dans la dernière
année est-ce qu'on veut avoir quelqu'un
qui est confiant en l'avenir qui croit à
l'ouverture sur le monde où quelqu'un
qui est beaucoup plus dans une mentalité
je veux le dire je le dis comme je le
pense d'assiéger parce que françois
legault talent et nous dire qu'on allait
jusqu'à la nasa la louisianisation du
québec avec les questions d'immigration
moi je veux un québec confiant je veux
un québec ouvert je veux un québec qui
sent qu'il a le il est capable de passer
à travers la crise de manière
constructive et c'est ça qu'on va offrir
aux québécois vous en parlez de la
langue parlons-en vous dit la loi 96
votre au loin vous vous vous modifier la
loi sur la langue française en disant
c'est le libre choix pour le sujet tout
le monde qui le voeu pourrait aller
étudier en anglais dans ce noyau tous
les francophones tous les allophones
tout le monde pour être décidé de
choisir à partir du moment où tu es un
jeune adulte a le droit de faire ce
choix là je pense que le parti libéral
c'est aussi ce parti des libertés est en
droit de faire ces choix là mais projet
de loi 96 ya d'autres enjeux la clause
nonobstant qu'on introduit alors qu'il
ya eu ce même pas ça même pas été postés
devant les tribunaux toute la question
de la justice aussi pourquoi est ce que
le ministre doit mettre ses deux mains
dans la justice il ya des éléments
fondamentaux qui sont problématiques
avec le projet de loi 96 par contre on
connaît tous la nécessité pour nous de
continuer à promouvoir de protéger le
français c'est pour ça qu'on a fait 27
propositions avec un demi milliard de
dollars
récurrent pour la langue française je
vous dis que la loi va quand même trop
loin si vous allez assumer cette prise
de décision des visuels nous on va
diluer la loi 96 c'est pas la diluer
c'est la ronde inclusive c'est faire en
sorte que de reconnaître que c'est pas
vrai qu'un immigrant qui vient au québec
en six mois va maîtriser le français de
manière parfaite c'est pas vrai qu'on a
besoin d'imposer ou cégeps anglophones
d'empêcher des francophones de pouvoir
aller au cégep anglophone c'est pas vrai
qu'on a besoin d'avoir une clause
nonobstant sur le projet de loi 96 alors
on est capable de le protéger de
promouvoir sans s'en aller avec le
projet de loi 96 dans son entier loi 21
sur les signes religieux vous êtes on va
enlever ça cette interdiction la de
porter le voile pour les enseignantes
vous dites ça c'est non dès qu'on arrive
on enlève ça et là vous le dites
vous-même porter le voile mais c'est les
signes religieux de manière de manière
générale n'est ce pas ces deux dire est
ce que ça change réellement quelque
chose pour les profs est ce que est ce
que c'est vraiment ça qui va faire en
sorte qu'on va être une société qui est
laïc on est une société laïque je suis
pour la laïcité de l'état on n'a pas
besoin d'imposer sa dans nos écoles pour
les signes pour les signes religieux
alors chaque chaque étape ça va toujours
trop loin encore une fois comme on l'a
vu avec la question de réunification des
familles avec françois legault est allé
jusqu'à dire que la réunification des
familles sa porte est une menace à la
nation québécoise c'est allé beaucoup
trop loin et c'est ça qu'on développe et
c'est certainement pas dans cette
direction là qu'on va aller comme
formation politique migration quel
serait le seul idéal dominique anglade
pour vous aujourd'hui on accueille
aujourd'hui en 2022 la c70 mille
personnes qui sont accueillis
aujourd'hui au québec donc nous on dit
prenons le chiffre qui est actuel parce
qu'il ya eu un rattrapage qui s'est fait
cette année et après ça travaillons avec
chacune des régions pour savoir quel est
le quel est le chiffre idéal mais pour
chacune des régions parce que c'est elle
aussi qui vont être capables de mesurer
ce sera au tour de 72 70 milles dans un
premier temps puis après ça chacune des
régions pour adouber nous on pourra en
apprendre davantage aux prêts emprunts -
ça va dépendre de la capacité de
logement vous savez qu'on une crise du
logement au par dessus toutes les autres
crises qu'on a présentement donc et on
pouvoir justement donner un pouvoir aux
régions c'est d'être capable aussi de
déterminer combien de personnels sont
capables d'accueillir et il faut pas
voir les l'immigration comme étant et
qu'en même temps une faiblesse ou une
menace pour la voir comme étant une
force mais pour ça il faut savoir aller
ça pourrait aller chez plus élevé
comment comment vous allez des termes
mais je compense j'avais mado région
mais comment vous allez déterminer année
1 1 et 2 ont bon dos à 75 80 70 comment
vous faites la capacité d'accueil
devrait déterminer pour chacune des
régions vous comprendrez monsieur roy
que de toute façon il ya une limite
aussi avec avec le logement il ya des ya
des limites avec les écoles et un
certain nombre de choses qui vont être
acquis qu'ils vont faire en sorte que tu
peux pas monter ce chiffre là de manière
importante mais au delà du chiffre on
vit une crise de main d'oeuvre qui a des
conséquences réelles sur les services
publics sur notre économie sur des
entreprises qui se délocalisent il faut
aussi prendre acte de sa puis de se dire
comment va se donner les moyens de
parvenir à développer notre économie
petite rafale il me reste plus tard mais
des petites rafales un médecin par
québécois qu'il veut vous revenez avec
ça est-ce que encore quelqu'un qui croit
cette promesse au québec on n'a pas le
luxe de laisser tomber ça on peut pas
avoir un million de personnes qui n'ont
pas de médecin de famille aujourd'hui
plusieurs camps n'auront pas dans les
branches doivent ou comment on fait mais
premièrement on n'en forment davantage
on implique davantage d'infirmières mais
aussi en revoit l'étagé médecin de
famille avec toutes les tâches qu'ils
ont dans les activités médicales
particulières on s'assoit petit on voit
comment est ce qu'on est capable de
ramener davantage dans les cliniques on
peut pas laisser tomber cet objectif
maison des aînés en terminant vous
faites quoi c'est pas clair là j'ai lu
il ya des projets en quarantaine des
gens construction fait quoi avec ça
cette idée de construire des maisons oui
plus coûteuse mais plus agréable en
principe pour les personnes âgées mais
la meilleure maison pour les aînés de
l'acsl c'est la vôtre c'est celle dans
laquelle vous résidez c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous on veut que les
personnes aînées puisse rester à la
maison donc c'est pour ça qu'on met une
allocation pour les aînés de 2000 $ dont
je comprends mais un acquis doivent être
placées malheureusement qui n'ont plus
alors est-ce que le programme de
construction de maisons des années se
poursuit ou non il va être il va être
nécessairement il va être nécessairement
revue vous avez vu les coûts
astronomiques puis les maisons pour des
aînés a même pas de main d'oeuvre pour
pouvoir soutenir soutenir les maisons
pour les aînés alors je pense que toute
révision des coûts qui va devoir se
faire par rapport à ça mais encore une
fois j'insiste il va falloir qu'on
investisse bien davantage sur le
maintien à domicile et bien dominique
anglade un rôle temps de décortiquer
encore plus à fond vos propositions la
campagne est bel et bien commencé
merci beaucoup à très bientôt au revoir
au plaisir à voir